[Music]
this morning on the dish a visit to pig
beach
this growing brand is the brainchild of
three friends who were trying to remake
the world of barbecue they opened their
first location in brooklyn new york in
2016. a second in neighboring queens
just a month ago
florida is next none of those spots are
traditionally considered barbecue
destinations but that is changing fast
to get the whole story we met the team
including chef matt abdul
and sampled
the whole hog
so the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna take our baby back ribs and
just take the container and shake it
over the top of it yeah okay every angle
every bit of it because you want every
bite to have that delicious seasoning on
it
[Music]
combine great ingredients great friends
and a craving to bring authentic
barbecue to unlikely places
the result is this
pig beach when i moved here in 96 there
wasn't any barbecue there was one two
barbecue restaurants
so i started doing it myself shane
mcbride matt abdu and rob schwager are
the triumvirate behind pig beach named
for the famous swimming pigs of the
bahamas
just a few years back both mcbride and
abdu were award-winning chefs in fine
dining kitchens in abdu's case it was
the fame new york city restaurant del
posto
until he got tired of it i think i got
to a point within that journey
where
i kind of just
got tired of a meal costing so much for
my friends family and loved ones that
wanted to come and support me and it
would happen all the time they would
want to come in and see what i was doing
at del posto
but you would leave there with a minimum
of like a 200 to 250 check per person
and it just sort of was like i don't
know it just kind of made me sad at
times abdu and mcbride teamed up with
schwager to open a pop-up dedicated to
barbecue in 2015 they took their recipes
to the world championship barbecue
cooking contest in memphis and won a
first place and second place award the
first team from the northeast to do that
ever when they called our name to final
it was like new york new york they're
like
who from new york is is in a final here
so we certainly broke the mold a little
bit on that first year down there and
that ended up be becoming our catalyst
that was like wow we're kind of onto
something we're pretty good at what we
do and rob is like why don't we take
this the next step soon there was a
fixed location in brooklyn and just a
few months ago they opened an enormous
new pig beach outpost in queens
here is a beer garden meets barbecue
meets burgers but with the jumbotron and
the size of the facility what we do at
pig beach we want families to come in we
want to bring the kids we want people to
spend the day come watch a game
sample all our food
pork pig pork is pig here family and
friendship are the focus just as much as
food
in part because of what happened three
years ago
one of their chefs jeff michener matt
abdu's brother-in-law was at work when
he developed a brain aneurysm he died at
the age of 36 leaving behind a wife and
16 month old child
his pig beach brothers hold frequent
fundraisers in his honor within our
career of cooking there is basically
the best way that we know how to honor
somebody or to show our love and
affection is is to cook how does he
still affect this place he well he's
within me he's everywhere what do you
think he would think of what you've
built now i think he is super jealous
that he's not here to be a part of it i
was going to say the same thing because
he wishes you would be here this is this
was his dream
pig beach's brisket sandwich is named
for jeff
part of a menu that includes all the
staples you ready for a snack i am ready
for a snack prepared the pig beach way
you can smell that porky goodness from
everything smell that oh my god i'm a
baby and for a treat
that's for you thank you how am i
joining you
oh yeah
oh man
what we want to do is we always approach
every single piece of food that we cook
with that sort of chef mindset you
seeing this are you seeing this
we're looking at it is how can we
perfectly balance sweet salty fatty acid
umami getting all these flavors
perfectly balanced to make the best bite
possible i could eat these all day
believe it or not you do end up getting
sick of it after you cook them every
single day but
i can't imagine it but sometimes doing
the barbecue all you want the other day
is a nice salad
don't worry about that what about that
later favorite barbecue item ribs
ribs
brisket
are we eating all of that today and more
more indeed
our dish spread included
barbecue buffalo wings with alabama
white sauce
pig beaches smash burgers
collard greens yankee sausage with
cherry pepper relish
salt and pepper brisket
tangy vinegar pulled pork
greek seasoned smoked lamb shoulder with
new york city white sauce
those amazing peach and honey glazed
ribs
and an entire 120 pound pig
it's like barbecue heaven you ready yeah
it's a little bit of the taste of the
belly of this pig we're gonna pull it
out just like that and you're gonna see
this amazing bacon
just pull
right out just so effortlessly all juicy
twist it up
and you have your first bite
this is mine whole hot pork belly
indoctrination into the team oh my god
it doesn't get any better than that does
it insane right
melting in your mouth in your mouth the
pork belly the whole hog that's arguably
one of the best bites on the pig and one
of the things you're not allowed to
submit into the box for judging because
it's like cheating because it's too good
that's the ultimate expression of
barbecue cooking a whole animal
that's like
true
barbecue you're talking that's a 24-hour
commitment for one item of food how to
manage a fire managed to smoke how you
get flavor into a whole animal and it's
some of the best times because we're up
all night together so the the
storytelling the drinking i mean you're
up all night feeding fire and watching
that
your baby in that cooker
do you believe that someday new york or
this area can be
regarded as highly as places in texas or
tennessee i think it's already getting
there yeah because there's a lot of
great talented people
that are pursuing this bug of barbecue
and it's becoming more and more of a
national
cuisine versus when it was solely
restricted to the southern south states
or the midwest
there is another location opening by the
way in louisville and you're
i mean i'm sorry
this is the chicken sandwich on the
plate we have the chicken sandwich spare
ribs coleslaw beans uh collard greens
and then over here there's the wider
shot of wow i have the tea we got
brisket which is good luck to you yeah
you cut the sandwich and let's see here
we go